j'ai 100 ans et trois mois un peu plus
au courant
aux États-Unis se dirige-t-on vers un
nouveau duel Biden Trump en 2024 Joe
Biden vient d'annoncer officiellement sa
candidature pour un deuxième mandat le
candidat démocrate qui aura 82 ans l'an
prochain vient de dévoiler un clip 4 ans
jour pour jour après sa dernière entrée
en campagne
[Musique]
elle est très rigoureuse et puis elle
est joyeuse c'est aussi quelqu'un de
très positif et mal le communique il
faut vraiment être
dans l'alignement faut pas être comme ça
démocratie dévalors essentielles pour
les Américains et en sous-tex de ce clip
de campagne la menace du retour de
Donald Trump
[Musique]
traduction
à l'âge de 80 ans Joe Biden apparaît
pour les Américains comme un président
trop vieux pas assez en forme pour
reprendre les clés de la maison blanche
une seconde fois j'ai 72 ans il est plus
vieux que moi il est vraiment trop vieux
pour ce job moi je me dis que je dérive
mais c'est parce que je me marre ah bah
oui c'est beau donc c'est pas grave donc
c'est pas grave voilà donc j'en suis
très contente finalement à son âge
s'ajoute ces chutes
sa difficulté parfois à aller au bout
d'une phrase
l'Amérique est une nation qui peut se
définir en un seul mot
et c'est bourdans public
plus de la moitié des femmes de mon
gouvernement de mon administration sont
sont des femmes c'est le problème d'être
un connard mais je revendique moi je
suis aussi con que
tu peux me le dire on est tous les deux
oh non je peux pas dire son nom elle est
encore patronne de France 2
vous allez voir ils ont chaussé des
talons rose bonbon c'était il y a
quelques jours voilà on les voit en
train de de marcher autour d'une table
de conférence cette vidéo a été publiée
par le ministre des Transports Canadiens
lui-même bon alors vu comme ça on a
l'impression qu'il passait un bon moment
il rigole il se dandine mais moi j'ai
toujours je me suis toujours j'aurais
bien aimé être une femme vraiment pour
la douceur pour la gentillesse l'exemple
de ma mère jusqu'au jour où j'ai croisé
cette dame là et ça m'a consolé
définitivement d'être un homme d'accord
on va sauver du plaire mais le sujet est
en fait très sérieux parce que cette
vidéo elle s'inscrit dans le cas d'une
campagne pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes une campagne
qui a été lancée par une association
féministe basée au Canada cette petite
Barbie là elle est équipée d'un appareil
auditif parce qu'elle est malentendante
et puis cette Barbie là elle est elle
est atteinte de trisomie 21
et elle est sortie aujourd'hui en
exclusivité qu'est-ce qu'on doit en
penser moi je pense que déjà il y a un
enjeu de représentation de
représentativité c'est à dire que toutes
les petites filles devraient savoir
qu'il y a une Barbie qui leur ressemble
ne serait-ce que ça mais en revanche
j'ai tendance à croire que c'est Barbie
s'adresse d'abord aux adultes avant de
s'adresser aux enfants promouvoir en
s'amusant voir en se moquant c'est la
stratégie de communication étonnante
adoptée par le compte Tik Tok officiel
des Jeux paralympiques
le plus gros succès de la chaîne le
voici une musique remixée pour
n'entendre plus que left
gauche pour un cycliste amputé de la
jambe droite
[Applaudissements]
on a appris la mort de François Léotard
à l'âge de 81 ans mère de Fréjus pendant
20 ans il a occupé les postes de
ministre de la Culture puis de la
défense il avait aussi été à la tête du
parti centriste l'UDF à la fin des
années 90 il avait quitté la politique
au début des années 2000 condamné en
2021 à 2 ans de prison avec sursis dans
l'affaire Karachi sur les
rétrocommissions versées durant la
campagne présidentielle de Balladur seul
le ministre des PTT Gérard Longuet a dit
quelques mots il envisage a-t-il dit la
suite des événements avec sérénité vous
allez le voir sur ces images dans
quelques secondes regardez bien je suis
du signe du Poisson les poissons sont
muets
voilà
faut mettre la tête en bas mais il a pas
100 ans
c'est encore une autre posture
mais la photo de famille ou la photo de
clan livrée déjà une partie de la
décision de Monsieur Lothar d'une
certaine façon pour nous observateurs